hi I'm just seeing I'm a hoarder I know
you've all seen the hoarders television
show we're not that bad so as you can
see behind me I have a very messy office
area you've been following me on my
other iJustine youtube channel then
you've seen some of the progress I
believe today I finally officially got
my desk in I just heard the backing out
of a truck I looked out my little wooden
no I'm just talking
my desk is finally here this disaster
area will soon be pretty and beautiful
and hopefully this desk will be the
answer to all of life's still solutions
answers questions god I'm losing my mind
because I work and live in sort of the
same space so it's kind of hard at
you're trying to just keep everything
all contained and and
I just noticed that I'm shooting this
video with 60 frames a second so it's
gonna look a little weird anyway I want
you guys to kind of help me design my
office space I would like to get a few
paintings I would like to get some
organizational things I'm also thinking
about getting a rug let me know I am NOT
an interior designer but I do sort of
know if something looks good or not so I
need your YouTube interior designer
expertise just my thoughts I would like
a teal big area rug back here do I want
a round one do I want to square one I
don't know I'm gonna go get this desk
started